i'm calling uh warner bros please can
you put me through
dc yeah thank you i'm on it don't worry
we're all gonna die
i hope so oh for god's sake
it's its own thing you know it's not a
sequel prequel
or a reboot really because there's some
characters
crossover you know that that people met
in
suicide squad the one directed by david
air um
and then there's a whole ensemble of new
characters you know
dave for example plays polka dot man a
lot of obscure characters that people
may not have heard of but i feel like
that's kind of
a james gunn signature move to take
these you know i think he likes to give
people something they didn't know they
wanted until they got it and they
realized
hey i really like this i think the main
difference was also the rating i mean
this is an r-rated film
and the humor is really pushing the
boundaries
the violence is like you know like
there's sharks ripping people in half
and um but it's the kind of violence
that's very like sensationalized
and fantastical and so it kind of fits
with the world and it's also
you know it's still fun it's very very
fun but yeah i'd say i'd say
i don't it's its own thing it's kind of
like the comic books when you pick them
up
depending on who the author is the look
might be different the tone might be
different it's kind of like that
david i know you're you're a huge nerd
i know um did you know much about polka
dot man though because
for me like completely obscure why you
gotta call me out on that ash yeah i'm
losing
i literally have done an interview with
you where you're like i'm in nerd
nirvana with all my projects so i feel
like i'm allowed to say it
i am i am in nerdvana right now i'm in
actor vanna i'm in
all the vanna's um but i will say um
when jane sent me this text out of the
blue i was in scotland
and i got a text from james gunn that
said i want you to be part of the
suicide squad
and then we got on the phone and he
started telling me about polka dot man
and
he knows what a nerd i am and i was like
i got
i got nothing i got nothing he's like
perfect that's exactly what i wanted to
hear
you're gonna be perfect for abner and um
yeah
it was uh and now i know
everything
well margo every time you play harley
you're kind of thrown into a completely
different environment almost like
different worlds
what excited you most about this
iteration of harley that we see in the
suicide squad it's excited that she's
kind of
you know she's definitely independent
from mr jay
for the first time even though when
birds pray they'd broken up at the start
she was still very much not okay with
not being with him
and in this one he's kind of like you
know she's not even thinking about him
which is really fun and just a new
interesting
mindset and place for harley to be in in
her life so she's looking for
new love and she's looking in all the
wrong places
i i love um boy crazy harley quinn i'm
like very curious what her
dating profile looks like me too because
they're always my favorite comics too
when she's like going on dates and like
messing it up
or it's a police officer or whatever
like those are always my favorite comics
i just i love
yeah harley single harley trying to date
she's a badass she doesn't need nobody
she does it but
he also loves she loves guys and
sometimes
sure my four-year-old is obsessed with
harley quinn and we had a harlequin
birthday party back
in june or yeah for in june for a penny
so
yeah okay oh cute those pictures are so
good i love that margo since since you
do kind of get to mix it up with with so
many different characters in this world
have you seen that
in the heights as leslie grace is going
to be a batgirl and do you feel like
you two could teach yes she's gonna be
how cool
that's wicked she's amazing so
i would like to see it i feel like it
makes sense for you two to do something
together
yeah i'm calling uh warner bros please
can you put me through
dc yeah thank you i'm on it don't worry
i'm also amazing
well because i i saw a headline recently
that you maybe wanted to take a break
from harley i don't know how
uh embellished that was what does that
next chapter look like are you gonna
take a little break from harley
no i've had enough of the break i'm
ready to do her again this is
i i i did birds of prey and
the suicide squad back to back so it was
a lot of harley
all in one year period um
but that was a while ago now i'm i'm
always ready for more harley i love that
i love it the sitcom like harley
harley.com i don't know there's there's
so many stories to do
honestly like a tv show i would love it
anyway just pitching ideas david um
quickly
polka dot man's powers very vicious a
little bit
probably the roughest ones tell me yeah
i mean
it's such a fascinating thing with with
the character with abner to think about
a guy who has this incredible ability i
mean he's
really truly i think one of the coolest
powers
on the team but um what it doesn't mean
anything
when you're in such a dark place and
when you've spent your life feeling like
a failure
and when you've suffered so much and
it's really interesting for me thinking
about that kind of
you know that that pain and that that
misery that abner has been living with
his whole life
up until this point um and
why he wouldn't have used these
abilities for anything other than
trying to get revenge on this cruel
world you know and then all of a sudden
we enter the story and for the first
time people
are treating him like he is for the most
part
part of the gang i mean you know
peacemaker is kind of a d
bag but everybody else is pretty cool
even harley like i saved your life from
one part remember
oh i mean i cherished that moment
forever
yeah forever they bonded after that
i'm a superhero
you